.
In this presentation, I want to solve some examples
Deals with contracts
Comparisons are what some students find
Difficult, but I think if I understand what I'm talking about
For him, you'll see that
The idea is straightforward
Sometimes you will wonder, why all
This?
The pairing is a
A relationship between two variables
If we assume that y = coupling x, all this
I mean, you gave me x
You can imagine this pairing as consumption for x
You insert x in this association
This pairing is a set of rules
You will say, oh, this x
I will link them with a value for y
You can imagine the process as a box
This is a coupling
When I give it a value for x, it will give me
The other number is y
This may seem brief
What are the values ​​of y and x?
Maybe I have an association - let me write it like this
Suppose I have a coupling definition
It seems so
For any value x you give, the output for it will be 1 if x
= - I do not know - 0
The output will be 2 if x = 1
Otherwise output will be 3
.
So now we have defined what is going on inside the fund
So let me draw the box around it
This is the fund
This is an arbitrary definition of conjugation, however
I hope it will help you to understand what
Being in pairing
If now if x is equal - if you choose x =
7, now how much will equal (f (x?
How much is f (7?
If we take 7 into the box
You can count it as a computer
The computer looks at x and then looks at its rules
Say, well, x = 7
Well x is not equal to 0. and x is not equal to 1
And go to the other case
So you enter the 3
If f (7) = 3
If as I wrote f (7) = 3
Where f indicates the name of the pairing, this base system, or
This relationship, this representation, ie
Of these names you can use them
When you give it 7, the output will be 3
When you give this 7, the output will be 3
How much product (f (2?
Well, this means that instead of x = 7, you'll
Give x = 2
Then the microcomputer within the pairing will
Say, well, let's see, when x = 2
No, I'm still in the other case
x is not equal to 0 or 1
If again f (x) = 3
Now, what happens if
So, this f (2 also equals 3
Now what happens if x = 1?
Well in this case will turn to this
If 1 (1)
Will go to its bases here
Oh see, x = 1
I use the rule here
If when x = 1, I will get 2
If (f) 1 equals 2
The output of f (1, 2) is extracted
This is a pairing
Now, since we have all this, let's solve some of these examples
They told us about all this
We evaluate these different associations
Different boxes have been created - on this
Different points
Let's solve one part first. They have defined the fund
f (x) = -2x + 3
They want to know what happens when f = -3
Well f = -3, this tells me what to do
Do x?
How much will the product?
When I see x, I replace it with 3
If equals -2
Let me do it that way, you see what I'm doing exactly
3, I will write it in bold
2 x 3 + 3
Notice that whenever you see x, put its place-3
If I know what the output will give him the black box
This equals -2 × 3 =
6, + 3 = 9
If f (-3) = 9
What about f (7?
I will do the same again, f - I will type 7 in color
Yellow - f (7) = -2
X 7 + 3
+ 3
If this equals 14 + 3, that is equal
Put - let me make it clear - put 7
In pairing here f and be output -11
That's what he explains to us
This is the rule
It's similar to what I did above here
This is the base pairing that we have
Let us solve the following example
I do not want to solve part b
You can do it in order to enjoy
I will then solve part c, for the time
Now we have reached f (0
I will use one here
I think you understand the idea. (f (0
Wherever you see x, you will set 0
If -2 × 0 + 3
-2 × 0 + 3
Well, the output is 0
If f (0) = 3
Then the last one. (f (z
They want it to remain brief
I will color it
(f (z
Let me type the z in a different color
Anywhere I see x, I will
Replacing it with z
Instead of x, we will put z
We will put z orange here
-2 × (z + 3)
This is the answer. f (z) = -2z + 3
If you imagine the box, the coupling f
Put z, you get -2 x
z + 3
That's all
It's a bit brief, but it follows the same idea
Now let's solve part c here
Let me explain it
I walk quickly
Let me clarify all this
I can solve part c
I will skip part b
You can solve that part
Part b
They tell us - this is the definition of pairing
Sorry, I said that I will solve part c
This is the definition of pairing that we have
f (x) = 5 (2 - x) / 11
So let's apply these different values ​​to x, these
Various inputs in pairing
If - f (-3) = 5 (-2)
We saw x, we replace it with 3
(II-III) / 11
This equals 2 + 3
Which equals 5
If we get 5 x 5/11
This is equal to 25/11
Let's solve this
(f (7
For the second coupling here, f (7) = 5
× (2 - - Now the value of x is 7
(2 - 7) / 11
So how much is this?
2 - 7 = -5
5 x -5 = -25/11
Finally, we have two left. (f (0
This equals 5 (2 - 0) and this is equal to 2
5 × 2 = 10
If it equals 10/11
another one
(f (z
When we see any x, we'll
Replacing it with z
This equals 5 (2 - z) divided by 11
This is the answer
We can distribute the 5
You can say that this is equivalent to (10 - 5z) divided by 11
We can also write it at the intersection of the inclination
This is equivalent to 5 / 11z + 10/11
All are equal
But this is the output of f (z
right Now
Pairing, as I said, is that if you give me any value for X, you will
I give you a product
I will give you (f (x
If this is the pairing given to us, give me x, and be
Output (f (x
Only one f (x) can be produced for any x
Our coupling can not be produced
Two possible values ​​for x
If there is no coupling - it will be
The definition of this association is illogical - f (x) = 3 if
Was x = 0
Or it can equal 4 if x = 0
Because in this case, we do not know what the result of f (0
how much?
If x = 0, it should be 3 or can be -
we do not know
no Yes
This is not even coupling though
It seems so
Not a conjunction
If we can not have two values ​​for (f) x for one value for x
So let's see which of these graphics represent associations
To find its value, you can say, see any value for x
Here - select any value for x - I have one value for f (x)
This is y = f (x
I have only one - at this x, this
The value of y that I have
You can have a vertical test line, which shows it on any
Point If you draw a vertical line - note that the vertical line
For a specified x value
Explains that I have only one value for y on this point
If this pairing is true
At any time you draw a vertical line, intersect
With representation only once
If this pairing is true
Now what about this?
I can draw a vertical line, let's say, on
this point
For x those, it seems that this relationship has
Two possibilities for f (x
(f) x This value can be either f (x) or that value
Right?
We have split twice with acting
If this is not coupling
We have done exactly what I have described here
For a given value of x, we describe two possibilities for y
They can equal (f (x
If this is not coupling
Same thing here
I drew a vertical line here
I split twice with acting
This is not an association
You define two values ​​for y for one value for x
Let us move on to this pairing
It seems a strange conjunction
It looks like a true mirror
But at any time you draw a vertical line, you will
Only one time
If this pairing is true
For each x, we have only one y
Or (f) x one common with it
Anyway I hope you have found this useful